the world's largest rainforest is in
flames burning at a record weight the
smoke is traveling far and wide really
said this has tainted Brazil's image
abroad as well dr. Alexander Kublai has
seen close up the impact deforestation
can have in the Amazon he says Brazilian
President bola Serrano is to be blamed
for these fires and the solution lies
with government policies there's a
long-term solution which is high
enforcement a lot of this fire is
happening in like I said the forested
areas and most of the deforestation more
than 80% of the forestation of brazilian
amazon at least is illegal so it's
happening in protected areas and
indigenous lands and so the for
enforcing this and preventing this
illegal activity which is actually
criminal would lead to the long term
reduction of these of these fires in the
Amazon the areas are so large there is
hardly anything firefighters can do to
put them out fires across Brazil's
rainforest have increased 83% that's
72,000 so far this year compared with
just over 40,000 in 2018 since last
Thursday satellites have spotted more
than 9,500 new forest fires and the
problem is not just confined to Brazil
Bolivia's government has also reported
that nearly 500,000 hectares of forest
have been left burnt by wildfires
the rainforest produces 20% of the
oxygen in the atmosphere protesters who
gathered outside a Brazilian Embassy in
central London today are demanding
action from world leaders two weeks of
raging fires sweeping through the Amazon
rainforest campaigners say this is
evidence of a climate emergency and
what's happening matters not just for
Brazil but the entire planet
no Philips Sky News